el cáncer de esófago es una enfermedad
que comienza en el esófago
el esófago es un tubo muscular por el
que pasan los alimentos desde su boca
hasta su estómago
las células planas y delgadas que
recubren el esófago se denominan células
escamosas debajo de la superficie las
células se dividen y se aplanan para
formar nuevas células escamosas a medida
que las viejas se desgastan
si padece una afección llamada reflujo
gastroesofágico o hereje menudo tiene
reflujo de ácido desde su estómago hasta
su esófago
con el tiempo es posible que la hereje
haga que las células escamosas que
recubren su esófago inferior sean
reemplazadas por células glandulares que
forman una mucosidad denominadas células
kalish y formes este cambio en el
recubrimiento del esófago es una
afección denominada esófago de barrett
este cambio en el recubrimiento del
esófago de barrett puede provocar un
cáncer de esófago llamado adenocarcinoma
hay otro tipo de cáncer de esófago
llamado carcinoma de células escamosas
que ocurre en las células escamosas del
esófago
al igual que todos los tipos de cáncer
ambos tipos comienzan cuando el material
genético dañado o anormal dentro de las
células las hace crecer de manera
incontrolada a medida que las células
anormales comienzan a multiplicarse se
forma un tumor
con el tiempo se puede formar un nódulo
en la pared del esófago a medida que
crece el tumor
posiblemente no tenga síntomas en las
etapas tempranas del cáncer de esófago
y luego posiblemente tenga dificultades
para tragar cuando el tumor se vuelva lo
suficientemente grande como para
bloquear parte de su esófago
si tiene dificultades para tragar
probablemente tenga dificultades para
comer como resultado es posible que
pierda peso en un corto periodo de
tiempo según el lugar en que esté
ubicado el tumor es posible que sienta
dolor en el pecho o en el cuello
si padece cáncer de esófago es posible
que su médico les recomiende algunas de
las siguientes opciones cirugía
quimioterapia
y radioterapia
y la cirugía es el tratamiento más común
para el cáncer de esófago en particular
en las etapas tempranas cuando el tumor
es pequeño
si se somete a un procedimiento
quirúrgico su médico eliminará la parte
del esófago que contiene el tumor
así como también el tejido normal que
está alrededor y sobre el mismo
posiblemente la cirugía incluya extraer
partes del estómago se unirán las partes
saludables restantes del esófago y del
estómago entre ellas
posiblemente el cirujano eliminé los
nódulos linfáticos cercanos para ver si
las células del cáncer se esparcieron
en el caso de tumores más avanzados su
médico podría recomendar quimioterapia
como el tratamiento principal para
reducir el tumor antes de la cirugía la
quimioterapia usa fármacos para evitar
que el cáncer se sigue expandiendo ya
sea deteniendo o ralentizando el
crecimiento de las células de cáncer
es posible que su médico le recomiende
radioterapia como la radioterapia de
rayo externo además de la quimioterapia
y la radioterapia daña y mata a las
células del cáncer de esófago
algunas formas comunes de reducir el
riesgo de cáncer de esófago incluyen
buscar tratamiento si padeces reflujo
gastroesofágico o hereje
y dejar de fumar
y evitar el alcohol